thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
google death and this is what you'll get
as one of the first images
the figure is so ingrained in our
culture it's hard to separate death
from well death this iconic image of
death personified is a skeleton that
wields a scythe
and is named the grim reaper but why
to answer this question we have to look
at ancient religion and artwork aramaic
scripture
and yes the black plague how we
conceptualize death and how we choose to
personify it changes over time
and there's more to the grim reaper than
just doom and gloom
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
macabre images of death personified have
been around since at
least the late 13th century this
illustration the legend of the three
living and three dead
is often considered to be the first
known european image
of an animated skeletal death figure
it's based on a popular story also from
the second half of the 13th century
and i mean a very popular story with
versions in
french english italian and german the
story goes that three finely dressed
young men
aristocrats or sometimes kings are out
hunting when they come across
three animated corpses all in varying
stages of decay
to their horror they recognize them as
their own ancestors
or perhaps even the men themselves the
corpses warn the living trio of the
fleetiness of life
the grossness of death and the need for
repentance
turning the men toward a more righteous
path the frescoes of the composanto and
pisa are part of the piazza del duomo
known as the monumental cemetery or
holyfield
were also inspired by this story the
frescoes portray a flying death with
bat wings holding a scythe that same
century an event of global proportions
fundamentally changed humanity's
relationship with and perception of
death
the bubonic plague or what we now
commonly call the black
death its monumental spread in the mid
14th century and europe asia and africa
killed a huge portion of the global
population
how did we even attempt to manage the
horror of such widespread death
to give us more insight into the black
death here's caitlin dowdy of ask a
mortician
hi emily hi everyone so let's understand
that by the end of the 14th century
anywhere from 20 percent which is
already a huge percentage
to 75 of the global population had
succumbed to the bubonic plague
and yes that's quite a range but there
was inconsistent inaccurate record
keeping
and no reliable census or data
collection but anyway you slice it
just a monumental amount of death
causing economic psychosocial and
cultural effects on the population
turning death into a humanoid figure
death why he's just like
us may have been a way to help us cope
as the plague continued to rage on
skeletons and even
half-decomposed corpses became a common
visual trope
they emphasized the universality of
death and served as a reminder of death
as i am so you two will be
folks the three living and the three
dead story which i love
was just the beginning churches and
cemeteries across europe featured
allegorical scenes of the dolls macabre
showing skeletons corpses and living
people from all backgrounds
all walks of life interacting together
king
or popper no one was safe from the
plague
money and status can't save you
we also see the emergence of a singular
death standing over bodies or collecting
the dead
triumph of death motifs that illustrate
the huge numbers of dead the grave could
consume
this period also marks the appearance of
artistic renderings of these skeletons
with weapons
a bow sword sickle or scythe for example
in the mid 14th century the poet
petrarch wrote his poem triumphus mortis
trionfo del amorte
after viewing the composanto frescos the
text popularity
inspired more illustrations and
paintings depicting death as a skeleton
or a corpse
standing on a cart riding over a dying
population
with a large scythe over her shoulder
that's right
her shoulder does gender can be either
male or
female depending on the country and time
period those of us in the slavic and
germanic language groups more often
imagine a male grim reaper while a
female version has been more dominant in
romance and latinate languages
don't forget that much of european
culture harkens back to the same
greco-roman roots
thus male death gods in greek and roman
culture deeply influenced the grim
reaper's appearance
thonatos the winged greek
personification of non-violent death
has been compared to the grim reaper but
there are two main differences
thonatos is always male and he carries
away the dead
the grim reaper is more often
conceptualized as forcefully claiming
the deceased
cutting down lives indiscriminately
there's gernos
the male greek god of time who is often
confused with chronos
the ancient greek god connected to
agriculture portrayed as an old man with
a beard
sickle in hand the physical resemblance
of these three gods and the natural
associations with harvest
the passing of seasons and time aligned
them with death
and each other when renaissance artists
and authors were looking for ways to
depict death
they adopted elements from thanatos
geronos and chronos
and replaced the handheld sickle with
the larger more efficient
scythe just butting in here for some
side
facts during the same time in the early
14th century when we see the increase in
imagery of death as a skeleton in art
and literature
the long-handled scythe that you can use
standing up
was gaining popularity in the corn
harvests of medieval europe
size went viral in the corn harvesting
scene
it was a faster way of mowing than the
sickle and the increased productivity
meant fewer laborers were needed
but because of the strength and height
needed to use this larger tool
it was perceived as a masculine object
those who wielded sickles in the fields
were called
reapers those who used scythes were
mowers so the grim reaper
should technically be the grim mower
which just doesn't have quite the same
ring to it up to this point in medieval
history there are clear associations of
death with time and the harvest which
helps explain why this grim
reaper this figure representing death is
portrayed with scythe in hand
mowing down the living quickly and in
great numbers
much like the black plague
personifications of death continued to
be popular reminding the living of the
inevitability of their
end but death was also a symbol
of compassion waiting with open arms in
the afterlife
a sign of comfort and acceptance from
this came associations of death with
love leading to its portrayal as a
bridegroom of young maidens during the
renaissance period
and eventually as the eroticized demon
lover which gained popularity in the
18th and 19th centuries
so how did death come to be named the
grim
reaper that actually didn't happen until
hundreds of years
after the black death the word grim has
been in use since the late 10th century
to mean something
fierce cruel savage or harsh in
disposition
or action or fiercely angry the moniker
the grim reaper in reference to the
personification of death first appears
in english literature in 1847
in the circle of human life a partial
translation of an earlier german
devotional text
from 1841 that tracks the life of a
christian
so there you have it death as a figure
that takes lives with a scythe has been
around for a
long time but the name grim reaper is
more modern
the grim reaper pops up everywhere in
popular culture
the interpretation can be more
light-hearted like in death takes a
holiday from 1934
or meet joe black from 1998 or the tv
show
dead like me the reaper here is meant to
humanize death
and show that they have motivations and
physical forms much like humans
and it makes sense that in times of mass
death
we know a little something about that
right now it helps to see
death as not some terrifying invisible
indiscriminate force bearing down on us
but
something with a face maybe even a
personality
better that death is like a
bureaucratically focused dmv
worker annoying but relatable than
a black hole of nothingness it's easy to
see why that would make us less
anxious and i'm fascinated to see how
art and literature personify death
as we continue to fight and hopefully
recover from
the pandemic like caitlyn said
more relatable interpretations of the
grim reaper in the 20th and 21st
centuries
lessened the blow of his sights so to
speak it's the grim reaper dude
oh but whenever there is a large loss of
life in the real world
death returns to its allegorical role as
something to be feared
like in 1987 when australia used the
cloaked figure to raise awareness about
aids or more recently in 2020 when
political cartoonists and one florida
lawyer
used the grim reaper to emphasize the
dangers of covet 19.
around the world people evoked the
dramatic figure to emphasize
high death tolls by the global pandemic
or as a warning of what might meet
someone who fails to recognize the
significant dangers of the virus
death is both personal and collective
after all death is universal
thank you to ancestry for supporting pbs
was that your great grandmother keeping
the family together
was that your great grandfather paving
the way for change did they brave mother
nature and walk away
stronger did they face the unknown with
resolve and triumph
there is strength in every family story
ancestry can help you learn about yours
visit ancestry.com for more information
frescoes the text
i didn't either i was just like i'm
gonna go for it until someone tells me
not to
starting from trianford
okay thanks